The History of English in Ten Minutes.
Chapter Six: English and Empire or The Sun Never Sets on the English Language.
With English making its name as the language of science, the Bible and Shakespeare,...
...Britain decided to take it on tour...
...asking only for land, wealth, natural resources,...
...total obedience to the Crown and a few local words in return.
They went to the Caribbean looking for gold and a chance to really unwind,...
...discovering the "barbecue," the "canoe" and a pretty good recipe for rum punch.
They also brought back the word "cannibal" to make their trip sound more exciting.
In India, there was something for everyone.
"Yoga," to help you stay in shape while pretending to be spiritual.
If that didn't work, there was the "cummerbund" to hide the paunch.
And if you couldn't even make it up the stairs without turning crimson,...
...they had the "bungalow."
Meanwhile in Africa, they picked up words like "voodoo" and "zombie,"...
...kicking off the teen horror film.
From Australia, English took the words "nugget," "boomerang" and "walkabout"...
...and in fact, the whole concept of chain pubs.
All in all, between toppling Napoleon and the First World War,...
...the British Empire gobbled up around ten million square miles,...
...four hundred million people and nearly a hundred thousand gin and tonics,...
...leaving new varieties of English to develop all over the globe.